When I first came to the Aspen ideas
festival,
I was very intimidated because most of
the people here have written a book.
They are an elected official.
Oh,
they're running a multinational
corporation.
I spend much of my time in the
developing world,
in a mud hut where there's no running
water or electricity.
And I think what it's given me is to use
my own words is the,
as shown me the power within me.
And uh,
it has given me a voice and an
opportunity to be an advocate for those
people who really don't have an
opportunity to share their story.
And there are very few of the
individuals here,
as much as they have traveled and they
have been to the developing world,
they haven't had an opportunity really
to experience through the eyes of the
people who live there.
So what I value about this is that it's
given me an opportunity to share with
them and they are the policy makers.
And my hope is that I've been able to
maybe shape or influence them in such a
way that they're able to leave having a
better understanding of the people that
they touch.